So, you are looking at the project for
this course.
Notice how it's not responsive at all.
At the ends of lessons 2, 4, and 5,
you'll be challenged to improve
this site's responsiveness.
I want to make it super,
super clear that there is no
right solution to this challenge.
You'll hear us repeat throughout the
course that responsive design is an art,
not a science.
To improve your responsive design
skills, you'll just have to practice.
I'll be talking through
the decisions we made, and
the steps we took to make
this site responsive.
And I really don't expect your
answers to look anything like ours.
This course is all about
thinking responsively.
Sure, we want you to walk away with
a few new CSS tricks up your sleeves.
But more importantly, I want you to
walk away approaching responsive design,
from the right mindset.
I'm recording this video now after
having spent several months working with
Pete on this course.
Over this time I have
actually learned quite a bit.
I'd done some responsive work before,
but
I hadn't approached my sites the way
you'll be learning in a few minutes.
A few weeks into filming I decided
to revamp my personal site.
And this is what I came up with.
Now I know it isn't the prettiest
thing in the world,
but it's nicely responsive.
And believe it or not this website
actually only took a few hours to
build over a weekend, that wasn't too bad.
What helped is that I approached
responsiveness systematically from
the start instead of
just as an afterthought.
All this is to say, that thinking
responsively is a huge help for
your development.
So, are you ready to get started?
Are you excited to get responsive?
Let's get started.